My name is Aisha.
I was raised in Gifu,
in the countryside.
- Chipa: The countryside.
- Yes, so besides my siblings,
I had never seen anyone
who had the same skin color.
I was always bullied,
so I always asked my mom
why she married a Black person.
Why was I born
with this skin color?
But now I respect myself
and love my skin color.
Just three months ago,
I traveled to Nigeria
and I saw so many people
bleaching their skin.
It made me really sad.
I really like those
English lyrics.
Thank you very much.
She comes from
a diverse background.
She has the Japanese
"cool" side...
...and then the American Black
"groove" and open mind.
I am Japanese,
but I have Black roots,
and on the outside
I look like a Black woman,
but I am still
a Japanese woman, too.
I was born in Nigeria.
My parents divorced
when I was five years old.
After that, I lived together
with my sibling and my mom
and grandparents
at their house.
Since I look Black,
a lot of people would call me
"foreigner, foreigner."
In school, I tried to be
even more Japanese
than the girls my own age.
Being in an environment
where I felt like
I had to change who I am
in order to be accepted
was very stressful
to go through
when you were a child.
I would like to change
this situation
for even one child
in the future.
As for me, I am biracial
Japanese and Nigerian.
I was raised in Japan,
and my first language
is Japanese.
So when I date
a Japanese person,
we have no problems.
Chipa: You understand
the conversation.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
One thing we are talking about
is a difference in culture,
but what you're saying is that
you don't have a difference
in culture
(in dating Japanese men).
So which is the problem?
Is it the Japanese person
or us foreigners?
Chipa: For me, when I think
about why it's difficult
to date Japanese people--
when we have conversations,
the depth isn't there.
It's surface level.
You don't need to be
embarrassed.
I was in Miss Universe Japan
in 2020.
On the way home from rehearsal,
the police stopped me
and it was just before 12 AM.
I was holding a big bag
and walking around the station,
so the police stopped me.
They asked me
what was in my bag and whether
they could search my bag.
- Aisha: 12 at night?
- Raimu: 12 at night.
This was the first time
in my life that
a police officer stopped me.
At that time,
I thought it was because
I looked Black.
I felt shocked that they would
do something like that
based on how I looked.
So I had slightly complicated
feelings about this.
Oh, really? ...Is that so...
Be quiet.
When I decided I wanted to be
part of
the entertainment industry,
I feel there are still limited
opportunities in Japan,
and I want to change that.
For that reason,
I feel I need to stay in Japan.
As for me,
I've been living in Japan
since I was a child.
Through my work,
my goal and dream
was to give inspiration
to children
by playing diverse roles.
Right now, through my acting,
I want to give kids
of the next generation
hope for their dreams.
I think instead
of being offended,
we should teach them.